habiter dans une belle ville
il a été l'homme du moment et au bon
auteur compositeur il a affranchi son
public de la sortie de son dernier album
sorti tout récemment et intitulé le
dernier présent sa tournée débute en
octobre il sera le 24 à la batterie à
guyancourt avance au café de la danse en
décembre et ce au casino de paris en
juin voici alexis hk dans le kiosque de
rien c'est cadeau chaque instant comme
dernières présences quand on sent que
son but est là
ni chaque instant
comme d'heure
à présent
quand je sens la peur
le
le dernier présentait déjà j'aime bien
ce titre
ce que je trouve que enfin le présent
c'est un des seuls temps de l'indicatif
qui veut dire quelque chose qui est
comme un cadeau en fait d'un une
présence comme un dernier cadeau à
chaque fois et à force de nous parler de
la fin du monde
à la fin de l'année descendre là
normalement c'est le 21 la fin du mois
la tension il faut se préparer à force
de nous parler de ça ça m'a inspiré une
chanson qui dit c'est marrant c'est
marrant que le présent ce soit ça veut
dire la même chose que un cadeau comme
ça veut dire qu'il faut prendre chaque
moment comme comme un cadeau même si des
fois c'est difficile et c'est une
chanson qui parle de la difficulté de
s'aimer
que pourrais je paie un timbre à pour
pour m'assurer
taillieu
ombrageux
d'un album à l'autre déjà mon ont
vieilli en avance on n'a pas les mêmes
choses et à dire quand on a 25 ans quand
on a 38 ans enfin c'est ça c'est moi ça
me paraît presque évident dans la et
puis si on écoute bien même les albums
d'avant il ya deux shows une espèce de
gravité une part d'ombré mais celui là
en fait il prend peut-être plus les
choses à bras le corps de manière
parfois un peu plus grave plus
mélancolique mais avec une mélancolie
positive
je crois vraiment à l'amour entre les
gens je pense que contrairement à tout
ce qu'on dit sur la déshumanisation des
choses ainsi de suite moi je pense que
il ya une nouvelle génération de gens
qui en fait ne sont pas du tout
déshumanisé et ont envie d'être ensemble
et sont heureux quand ils s'en sont ils
pas mais
que le ciel ambitieux produirait potter
/
lorsque monsieur
il paraît
que les
dieu
la save
pour moi l'imaginaire
c'est important mais ça ça ne se fonde
que sur l'observation de la réalité sur
cet album là j'ai été plus intérieure
que sur les précédents mais je continue
à penser que si on veut écrire des
choses intéressantes il faut d'abord
commencer par regarder écouter et se
laisser étonné aussi parce qu'on a on
prend parfois la fâcheuse tendance de
s'habituer à être vives à vivre comme
une mauvaise habitude et comme si
c'était quelque chose qui allait
toujours durer mais dès qu'on s'arrête
un peu quand des noms mais c'est quand
même extraordinaire
c'est quand même étonnant dès qu'on
prend le temps de le faire
la vie reprend un tour surprenant et là
on peut commencer à être inspirés
tant que
ça
j'aime beaucoup faire appel
à l'époque médiévale mais façon bakou -
12 quoi c'est à dire vraiment faire un
clin d'oeil à l'époque médiévale de
temps en temps parce que ça permet des
anachronismes aussi de langage comme ça
jamais jamais énormément laon plus pour
ignoble noble qui est un ovni absolue
moi je pense qu'il faut toujours qu'il
ya un ovni sur un album c'est très
important
il y avait aussi eu envie de
de partager avec renan luce et benoît
doremus qui sont des camarades de route
que j'aime pour l'éternité
chaque instant comme dernier présent
quand on sent
le
chaque instant
quand moderne
est présent moi j'ai vraiment grandi
entre mais comme beaucoup de monde entre
la chanson française et l'arrivée d'une
fois en france quoi où j'avais 13 ans 14
ans et où après quand c'est arrivé
on savait que plus rien ne sera comme
avant qu'il y avait vraiment quelque
chose de nouveau qui se produirait et ça
c'est obligatoire que si j'écris une
chanson qui fait une rétrospective sur
les époques que j'ai traversés as de
pique je suis enfin c'est obligatoire
que je fasse un petit clin d'oeil comme
ça pour dire ça faisait partie de mon
univers mais longtemps mais je suis pas
un rappeur quoi
et maintenant jeune padawan on retrouve
un nouveau sujet de la rédaction préparé
par la maîtresse jedi à johanna soudry
la force attirer de nouveaux publics un
versailles c'est tout l'enjeu du
partenariat établi entre le château et
des éditions glénat le 26 septembre
sortait le premier album de bande
dessinée peu crépuscule du roi nous
allons faire trois albums sur le sujet
trois albums qui seront indépendants le
fil rouge sera le château ce sera la
seule
le seul lien entre les trois albums qui
pourront se lire tout à fait
indépendamment
pourquoi ce choix comment vous est venue
cette idée c'est une collection que
développent les éditions glénat qui est
une question sur les grands lieux du
patrimoine
il ya un album sur le mont saint michel
sur carnac en bretagne
sur le panthéon sur le produit de
foucault est là donc il va aller voir
ses trois albums sur le château de
versailles et donc il ya des lecteurs de
bd qui vont découvrir vers salles à
travers leur livre favori manière de
découvrir les choses favorite
on peut découvrir versailles à travers
la musique les romans la peinture la
visite de versailles évidemment et bien
là on va la découvrir grâce à la bande
dessinée qui nous fait remonter dans le
temps puisque cette trilogie nous emmène
dans le futur et puis après va nous
ramener dans le présent pour nous
transporter ensuite dans le passé
je dirais que bon il est toujours une
certaine exactitude historique à
apporter mais on a aussi la possibilité
de parler les cadrages les prix les
couennes vu qu'on choisit d'apporter
aussi notre univers donc sans justement
repasser par le côté carte postale ou
films de déjà-vu donc c'est moi ce qui
m'a vraiment intéressé et ça c'est
d'essayer d'injecter dans versailles un
peu de mes visions à moi on commence
sans une histoire classique
traditionnelle ya un roi on connaît pas
trop son numéro mais enfin tout se passe
bien les nobles
font des histoires de nobles les
chambrière fin d'une histoire deschamps
brière et puis il ya quelque chose qui
se passe d'un seul coup on ressent des
petits anachronismes et des petites
choses anormales dans l'histoire ça ne
devrait pas se passer comme ça surtout
que après tout les serveurs sap et tous
robert et des robert qui servent les
robert partout ce robert de temps en
temps ils ont plutôt une allure de rbo
et ce château on ne peut pas en sortir
si on passe les grilles de ce château ou
rentrer dans un univers extrêmement
angoissant extrêmement anxiogène l'album
de science fiction le crépuscule du roi
sera suivi d'un deuxième tome intitulé
l'ombre de la reine le nom du dernier
album est déjà connu il s'agira du
sacrifice du fou
et encore quelques dates à noter avant
de ramasser les feuilles mortes à
l'appel le 19 octobre laurence equilbey
le coeur accentue se rendront un hommage
à bach au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le 20 octobre
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux vous
propose une soirée salsa avec le groupe
affine chaos
les 19 et 20 octobre la chorégraphe
japonaise kaori ito s'interrogera de
manière sensuelle et danser sur la
liberté à travers le spectacle island of
no memories présenté au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le 20 octobre
c'est denis podalydès qui présentera son
bourgeois gentilhomme au prisme et le
même jour la maison de la poésie
proposera son 19e cabaret politique sur
le thème quelle énergie
et n'oubliez pas que tous les mardis
vous pouvez gagner des places de
spectacle sur le site du kiosque
www.kia.ca qui point fr des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que
l'ensemble de la programmation des
salles saint-quentinoise sur internet
aux adresses qui s'affiche alors bon
spectacle à tous et à bientôt
ok